hey everyone I'm Abby sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen today's video is gonna be
sponsored by skill share and I will be
reviewing Maddie limb burner
now many of you have asked me to review
this channel and when I took a look at
some of her videos I was not surprised
by all of the interest now Maddie has a
pretty popular YouTube channel and
following on Instagram she's got a lot
of vegan lifestyle vlogs workout videos
vegan recipes travel entries and of
course a lot of what a in a day videos
we are gonna look at one of her more
recent what I need any videos at least
it was when I shot this video but who
knows by now honestly this girl pumps
them out so we could it be a few behind
so bear with us now before we go too far
I want to point out that my coffee game
is on point today thanks to this awesome
course I did through Skillshare last
weekend basically Skillshare is a
membership based online learning
community for creators who want to learn
everything from illustration photography
art film and video marketing and so much
more they also have lifestyle courses so
I thought it would be really fun to
learn about something that I love in my
spare time and what do I love more than
anything coffee so I did this eCourse
called plant to cup brew an amazing cup
of coffee that was hosted by the
director of training at Blue Bottle
Michael Phillips which is my favorite
coffee of life folks it is the best and
since I have unlimited access with their
Premium Membership I am super excited to
do more and I've got a great hook up for
my viewers two months a free Skillshare
so check out the link in my description
for more info and after that it's just
$10 a month so with my perfect Blue
Bottle coffee in hand let's get into
this
you
[Applause]
I have to admit I do not miss seeing
juicing in what a new day videos so see
her straining all of that vegetable and
fruit pulp that is the good stuff folks
do not throw that out oh sure it's a
concentrated source of vitamins and
minerals but most people who eat a whole
food diet don't really need that I mean
I haven't seen her whole day yet but in
general the types of people who drink a
lot of green juice are the people who
really are also eating a lot of other
fruits and vegetables ultimately if you
like juice of course please go and enjoy
in moderation and I love juice but I
wouldn't have it replace Whole Foods and
vegetables or water for that matter
starting today off with some green juice
today's the day after my birthday and
yesterday we ate a lot of good food but
last night before bed we ate cake and
ice cream and this morning I was feeling
like I just needed a little bit of life
in me and not I wasn't feeling like a
heavy like latte or something like that
so I'm starting off with a green juice
it's delicious
it's actually pretty good it's not bad
it's a little celery bit lemon in it
yeah okay so first of all happy belated
birthday Maddy awesome but second kind
of sucks that you have to drag yourself
through a juice that makes you cringe
because you had cake and ice cream last
night now I can fully appreciate feeling
a little bit bloated after a big
celebrity meal and the same way I talked
about it in my intuitive eating video on
vacation sometimes you just crave the
veg after something like that but green
juice or any vegetables can also be like
really refreshing and energizing
especially when you're feeling a bit
sluggish and bloated so it doesn't have
to feel punishing or gross or even just
bad we can still make it taste good
right so that would be my recommendation
make it taste good so it's not such a
punishment okay so now even her cat is
not down for the green juice you know
how they say that animals are really
intuitive
I trust that cat's palate I don't really
believe in the whole detox thing after
you eat a bunch of junk food and you
drink your green juice and you detox
from that that's not what I'm trying to
say here that's not what I'm trying to
do yeah I know but I just wanted to
reiterate that because you said you
trying to detox me and I'm not we just
said it does help you like kind of like
flush things out No so don't think that
don't do that okay so I'm glad that Nadi
clarifies this even though the way she
talks about using it like as a post
birthday meal send a little detox e to
me but I'm giving her the benefit of the
doubt for flagging it as for the
statement that it helps to flush you out
well yes I mean drinking any liquid will
help with that as does eating fiber
breathing sweating pooping all really
great ways our body gets rid of toxins
there's really nothing special about the
celery
fYI to microwave them so
have just some quick cook oats I'm gonna
add a little bit of cinnamon a little
bit of maple syrup some water mix it in
this bowl throw it in the microwave real
quick and easy and I'm also going to add
a few drops yes I don't think can you
see that I think so I don't think that I
have mentioned it on this channel yet
but the OL life came out with a
plant-based omega-3 supplement it's an
algae based supplement and it has 300
milligrams of EPA and 600 milligrams of
DHA and I've been using this ever since
its come out and it's amazing it has a
slight lemon flavor but honestly it's
pretty tasteless if you put it like on
top of food like I'm going to today just
a couple drops like so and all the times
I just pop it straight in my mouth cuz
it doesn't taste that bad at all if you
guys want to check it out read more
information on it I'll leave a link in
the description and as always you guys
can always use my code new customers
only will get a discount using the code
ninety ten literally took me like three
minutes to make how's that for a quick
and easy
put okay so that is simple I mean
simplest key for breakfast right and
I'll be honest one of my favorites it's
a great carbohydrate rich meal but I
would love to see a little bit more
protein and fat I see that we've got the
nuts on top which of course has those
healthy fats and the omega-3 supplement
but between the oats and the dried fruit
and the maple syrup it's still a pretty
carb heavy I do really like that Maddie
is sharing the omega-3 supplement that
she takes with her audience it looks
like an amazing supplement that a lot of
vegans or people who don't eat fish can
really benefit from the dosage of 300
milligrams of EPA and 600 milligrams of
DHA will definitely meet her Omega 3
recommendation needs so that's great
also I haven't really harped on this in
the past but I just realized that this
is totally an ADD
she just got a promo code in her
description and yes she doesn't disclose
the relationship that's a problem folks
I did a whole video about sponsorship so
you can check that out right here but I
would be so scared of the FTC coming
after me if I pulled a stunt like that
legally we have to disclose that there's
a partnership within the first 30
seconds and I didn't see a disclosure in
this video anywhere
I assume that Maddie isn't trying to be
deceptive and maybe just doesn't know
this but with almost 400,000 subscribers
I would really hope that somebody would
fill her in ASAP okay so before we see
Maddie's lunch she did talk about how
she basically did some meal prep and
popped it into the oven and while
everything is cooking she's gonna do a
little bit of a workout love the
multitasking meal prep girl let's take a
look
ooh I hate those one-legged squats all
right so let's take a look at the lunch
she's got cooking up here
[Music]
the dressing that I put on this is just
a teeny miso dressing that I had it's
the one that I used in my last video but
if you guys want to make a quick little
teeny dressing at home all you need is
some tahini maple syrup you can use
lemon juice if you want and then you
could also add in a little bit of hot
sauce if you want it to be a little bit
spicy and then you also need some warm
water to kind of thin it out oh my god
this lunch looks crazy delicious
first of all roasting vegetables is one
of my favorite ways to eat vegetables so
I definitely need to try this meal prep
recipe it's also a perfectly balanced
meal so we've got the protein from the
tofu and the chickpeas in there some fat
from the avocado and the tahini and the
olive oil plus some carbs from the sweet
potato and some bonus fiber from the
vegetables it's nourishing and satiating
and because of the combination of
protein and carbs it's really a perfect
meal to have after a workout big thumbs
up to this meal girl okay
now let's work on dinner and I just have
decided not to be super strict about oil
anymore because we started using it and
I don't see any difference in my skin I
don't feel any difference in my
performance and we really don't use that
much of it like for how much I'm gonna
make that's like a teaspoon I'm just not
as super strict about it I just it helps
us keep on our way because if you're
syllable fat all the time it yeah harder
because you haven't trying to gain
weight so I think oil has been helpful
but if you're trying to lose weight then
I wouldn't recommend using oil stick to
the whole know oil thing my whole
cookbook is completely oil free and it's
super easy to not cook with oil but
adding a little bit of oil here and
there
helps with flavor how's the flavor yeah
I do not like this I am so over the
misinformed no oil trend do not be
afraid of oil now the truth is every oil
has its own unique cooking baking and
health properties in fact I've got a
great infographic where I break down the
differences but
I mean a lot of common oils and fats so
check out that link in the description
below now a lot of proponents of the
oil-free diet
clean that oils lack nutritional
benefits because of its processing now
oil is a processed food so the argument
is that after processing any of the
benefits of oils are stripped away the
argument then follows that to get the
benefits of healthy fats oil free
dieters will instead consume whole foods
that the oils are extracted from so
things like avocados nuts seeds and
olives they also claim that oil free
diets can reduce the risk of heart
disease because some oils may increase
cholesterol levels it is true that in
some highly refined oils the addition of
chemicals in processing may reduce the
antioxidant and carotenoid content but
if you're concerned about this you can
always choose a cold pressed oil
whenever possible now with cold-pressed
oils there's no heating and instead the
seeds are cleaned and then crushed
slowly because of the limited refinement
these oils tend to have a more healthful
fatty acid and antioxidant profile
however it's important to note that
according to scientific evidence these
effects have just been shown in
cold-pressed olive oils we don't have
enough research yet on the benefits of
other cold-pressed oils like canola so
for vegans some of my personal favorites
are walnut oil and flaxseed oil because
they contain alpha linolenic acid which
is a vegetarian source of the omega-3
fatty acid now bottom line is that some
oils like olive oil carry heart-healthy
properties and can be really beneficial
for our health and they really should
not be avoided in an effort to lose
weight there is a reason why fat is back
in vogue these days fat makes us feel
more satiated and full not to mention it
also helps us absorb fat soluble
vitamins especially for Maddie who
follows a vegan diet oils can be an
excellent source of omega-3 fats which
has been shown to help reduce the
incidence of heart disease and stroke in
general I actually always recommend that
people consume oils in moderation and in
variety so that way they get a nice
varied fatty acid profile in their diet
[Music]
a blanket like what's the big buddy you
know tuck and roll tuck and roll oh my
god
burritos are my favorite and I love how
easygoing Matty is in the kitchen like
she likes to use whatever she has on
hand her meals seem really easy and
accessible and just easy to follow along
with like I love the idea of just like
branching em trying the walnuts you know
not every single meal is going to be
instagram-worthy
from a nutritional perspective I love
this dinner because it's got a nice
balance of protein from the beans in the
quinoa some healthy fats from the
avocado and the olive oil and some fiber
from the wrap beans and veggies love
love love me a burrito night birthday
celebration continues we still have ice
cream in the freezer
and if I don't eat it now then he's
gonna eat it and I'm not gonna be able
to eat it so coconut bliss ice cream bar
oh yeah baby I would say the perfect way
to end any what a new day video is ice
cream these bars are really delicious
I've had them and I'm totally craving
one right now but before I go grab my
own let's take a look at Maddie's
nutrition for the day so on this day
Maddie's consuming 2454 calories 32% of
which is coming from fat 55% from carbs
and 13% from protein so it looks like
Maddie's getting enough calories to meet
her high activity needs and her diet is
really well-balanced her macronutrient
distribution falls within the
recommended ranges
she's also meeting her essential fatty
acid needs by including those nuts seeds
avocados and those omega-3 drops as far
as her micronutrient needs she seems to
be meeting all of her vitamins and
minerals it's unclear whether she takes
a multivitamin or kind of specific
vitamins like D and b12 but if not
that's definitely something that I would
want her to consider adding I also love
that she's getting a
range of plant-based protein sources so
things like quinoa tofu chickpeas and
soy milk along with a nice variety of
carbohydrates as well like things like
oats sweet potatoes and quinoa a
carbohydrate and protein intake is also
really nicely time with their daily work
as to help refuel those glycogen stores
and aid in muscle repair and synthesis
so that is really great now let's
summarize what I really like about
Mattie's day first of all she's eating
enough calories I can see from Mattie's
channel that fitness is very important
to her so it's nice to see her properly
fueling her work as in her days with
enough calories she seems to follow a
consistent meal pattern with three full
meals a day this all ensure she's
meeting all of her nutrient
recommendations for the day so I think
that's really great number two she's got
some simple delicious balanced meals
I loved all of Mattie's meals like I
mentioned earlier they're easy they're
accessible and they're really well
balanced they also seemed pretty
thoughtful yet also intuitive and
spontaneous you know just based on what
is on sale or she has in the fridge I
think she's a great resource for vegans
to get some really healthy nutritious
meal ideas now let's talk about what I
think Maddy can improve on the only
thing and its minor that urged me a
little bit the wrong way with some of
the misleading claims around weight
management and oils there were a few
times in the video where Maddy made some
nutrition claims that just didn't really
hold a whole lot of bearing she also
mentioned that she's using oil now which
is great but only because she needs to
gain weight and she encourages people to
consume an oil-free diet if they're
trying to lose weight first of all
there's no evidence that suggests oil
free diets lead to weight loss and
restricting foods actually tends to have
the opposite desired effect we've talked
about this a million times there is a
lot of research that diets like the
Mediterranean diet which includes a wide
variety of fats from things like olive
oil can actually be really heart healthy
and can help with weight maintenance so
I'm glad she's not currently following
that but the fact that she's still
promoting an oil-free diet with her
cookbook seems misguided to me overall
though guys I'm really glad that you
pointed her out to me because she seems
pretty cool and I'm gonna continue to
enjoy her content so guys that is all
for today's video another
big THANK YOU to Skillshare for
sponsoring this video and for hooking up
my viewers with two three months of
their amazing membership program if you
loved this video be sure to give it the
thumbs up leave me a comment below with
other youtubers that you want me to
review subscribe to the channel and I'll
see you next time on Abby's kitchen bye